الاتجاه المتواصل بين الصين والولايات
المتحده والتحذيرات المتبادله لا تنتهي
فواشنطن تنتهي مبيجين بالرغبه في اعاده
تشكيل النظام الدولي وتفويضه وهو وتقويضه
وهو ما تعتبره الصين نشرا لمعلومات كاذبه
ومحاوله لتشويه سمعتها الخارجيه وصورتها
في شهر مايو الماضي هدد الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن خلال زيارته لليابان بان واشنط
سترد عسكريه في حاله هجوم الصين على
تايوان تلويح امريكيون باستخدام القوه
عقبه تحذير صبي اما وصفته باساءه تقدير
الالتزامها بحمايه سيادتها وتاكيد بانها
لا تسمح لاي قوه خارجيه بالتدخل في قضيه
تايوان باعتبارها شاننا داخليا وفق تعبيره
في اغسطس الماضي اثار زياده ورئيسه في
مجلس النواب الامريكي لتايوان غضبا صينيا
ووصفت بيجين التعامل الامريكي مع الزياره
بانه اللاعب بالنار في شهر اكتوبر الماضي
صنفت استراتيجيه الامن القومي الامريكيه
الصين ضمن تحديات الاستراتيجيه الاكثر
الحاحا بوصفها من القوه التي تضع الحكم
لاستبداديه في طبقه من السياسه الخارجيه
التحريسيه وفق تعبيرها في نوفمبر دعا وزير
الدفاع الصيني في عقاب لقائه بنظيره
الامريكي واشنطن الى احترام المصالح
الاساسيه للصين وفي بدايه هذا الشهر شدد
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه على ان بلاده لن
تسمح للصين باعاده تشكيل النظام الدولي
وقال ان معه الشنطن تعمل على اكتساب وضع
عسكريا اكثر فتن في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
والحذاء
معنى من بيجين مراسله الجزيره شيماء جوي
شيماء لعلك تلخص لنا
الموقف الصيني هذا الاجراء من واشنطن
من الجانب الرسميه سواء على الصعيد
العسكري بدا بتصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الصيني
الامريكيه التي وصفها بالمتدهوره
بعد يوم واحد فقط
العسكريه التي تجيزها لان تكون فوريه
لتايوان وتحدث بالتوازي عن ملف العلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه التي وصفها بالقويه ووصف
روسيا بالشبيك ان استراتيجيه القوي
والحليفه الدائم من الصين اذا هنالك
مقارنه واضحه في العلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه في نفس الوقت من خلال
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه الصيني الذي اكد
ايضا بان الصين لا تقف مع اي جانب او اي
طرفا في الازمه الاوكرانيه كما تصفها بيجن
والتي لا تريد ان فدي مصطلح الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا اكد دعم الصين الدائم
لحاليفه روسيا واكد ايضا بان 20 ستسعى الى
تعزيز العلاقات خلال الفتره المقبله
بالنسبه للعلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه وصفا
وين بانها متدهوره وبانه الصين التسعه لان
لا تكون الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كاول
قوه اقتصاديه عالميه ان تكون منافسا للصين
وتسعه رغم هذا التداول في العلاقه الى
تحسينها واعادتها الى مسارها الصحيحه لم
يشرعني خلال تصريحاته اليوم باي شكل من
الاشكال سواء تلميحا او مباشره الى قضيه
ملف تايوان والمساعده الامريكيه لكن من
الواضح هذا الطرح للعلاقه الرسميه
الامريكيه والعلاقات الروسيه الصينيه
بالتوازي مع المناورات العسكريه التي تقوم
بها الصين وروسيا في البحر الشرقيه
من الواضح انه هنالك ربا رفيقا بين هاتين
العلاتين عث من ناحيه اخرى بالنسبه
للمساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه لتايوان
وصفقات بيع الاسلحه لتاون فانها لا تسير
فقط حفيظه استقبال بل تعتبرها على اللسان
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه خلال
مناسبات سابقا خطا احمر لا يمكن تجاوزه
وهو التدخل في الامن القومي تهديد الامن
القومي الصيني وايضا تدخل صار في السياسه
الداخليه من فضلك شيماء
ناصر هذا هو الموقف الصيني اذا هو همم
تعتبر موضوع تايوان هذا خطا احمر
يعني هذه التصريحات مفاجئه الى حد ما في
واشنطن هذا الصباح عشيه او في غداه هذه
الايات يعني في غياب الاداره الامريكيه في
مواقع ها تاتي هذه التصريحات من الصين لكن
للتذكير فقط يبدو انها تصريحات تاتي رد
فعل على الميزانيه الجديده والموازنه
الجديده للولايات المتحده التي تم اضافتها
وتعزيزها بحوالها 18 مليار دولار اضافيه
لقضايا الدفاع تخصصه اوكرانيا تخص الصين
وتخصينا ايضا يبدو ان ما يثير حفيظه
الصينيين هو هذا التركيز الامريكي الان من
خلال وسائل الموازنه على الارقام
بالدولارات نتحدث هنا على ما يمكن
للولايات المتحده ان تفعل في حال ما تظهر
الاوضاعه وبتعرف حال هذه الميزانيه
الجديده وان كانت تبدو ان ميزانيه تستجيب
للحاجيات الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه الا انها
ميزانيه تتوقع وتنظر الى المستقبل هناك
سياسيا في واشنطن منظور ااه وتحليل
استراتيجي مستمر في البيت الابيض في
الخارجيه في البرتغال الامريكي وهو ان
الصين تستغل هذه المرحله من الحرب
الاوكرانيه لتعزيز التعامل مع روسيا ولكن
ايضا في لحظه المال للانقداد
الميزانيه الجديده الامريكيه والتي تضيف
تضيف حوالي 800 مليار دولار تدعم بشكل
واضح اجور الجنود الامريكيين في تايوان
مثلا همم توفر
الميكانيزمات والاليات السريعه للتدخل
وتقديم اي دعم لتاون عسكري هنا القصد اذا
ما تطلب الامر ذلك وهذا ما يبدو انه يثير
حفيظه الصيني لكن لدينا في مجموعه من
التصريحات الامريكيه المخاوف الامريكي
ليست بالحده ذاتها التي يتحدث بها
المسؤولون الروس لكن باللغه الديبلوماسيه
نسمع من همم
قبل ان فقط هنا في واشنطن بين الولايات
المتحده تعمل في جد عن طريق الوسائل
الدبلوماسيه
ليس لحصار الصين واينما تعمل مع دول
المنطقه والحلفاء لتستعد لكامل كما يصفه
وزير خارج امريكا التحديات التي تطرحها
الصين ولعل القصد هنا بالتحديات التي
يتحدث عنها وزير الخارجيه هي تلك ذلك
النمو
العسكري السريع ايضا الذي يراقبه الامريكي
ثم ايضا البيت الابيض يتحدث ويقول صراحه
لان المشكله الوحيده هي الصين في المنطقه
ويجب اذا الاتحاد ووضع كل الاحتلافات
المطلوبه استراتيجيا وعسكريا في المنطقه
كي تحمل الولايات المتحده مصالحها اكثر من
هذه اللغه حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لكم ناصر
الحسيني من واشنطن